you're the first male country artist to
perform at the awards show what was that
moment like i mean i had a blast would
love to do it again sometime
met taylor swift she was the first
female to do it as a country artist so
it was it was cool
everybody has never heard of me before
and they heard that song they probably
went down a rabbit hole my other music
just opened
for more artists which i've been trying
to do this whole time that i've been a
musician
[Music]
like i love country music has spent
seven weeks at number one at country
radio did you expect that this much love
for this song i didn't expect it to be
78 number one in canada so thank you
country radio but i do love the song
[Music]
[Music]
different man is the name of the album
what did you want to say with this new
music i feel like i just really found
myself as an artist i'm continuing to to
grow more but that's just that's
basically what i meant by different man
for the album
presented by travel texas from the
pristine gulf coast to incredible arts
culture and outdoor adventure texas has
something for everyone texas go big or
go home
[Music]